Republicans have yet again failed to
elect a speaker of the house despite
being poised to take control and swear
in their new elected members like George
Santos who has not actually been sworn
in yet even though he said he was we'll
get to that later despite the
endorsement of the failed former
president Donald Trump Kevin McCarthy
has lost again
and again
and yes again that makes it six total
times and this exposes number one the
complete inability to actually lead and
get things done productively even in the
easiest of circumstances like we have
control let's pick a speaker
it exposes increasingly the potentially
dwindling power and Prestige to the
extent extent that there was ever
Prestige of the Maga portion of the
Republican Party
and it also raises real national
security questions when you don't have a
speaker there are National Security
risks we will talk about that later as
well Rolling Stone reporting McCarthy
loses again despite nod from Trump the
House of Representatives has rejected
the California representative for a
fourth and probably not final time on
Wednesday subsequently rejecting him a
fifth time and then a sixth time and
then the voting set to pick back up
again today I'm sure by the time you
listen to today's program we may know
more there may have been more votes now
the despite the nod from Trump is very
interesting today's Thursday yesterday
was Wednesday on Tuesday when the first
votes for McCarthy failed
people uh NBC News went to Trump and
said do you still support McCarthy and
he didn't respond much later on in the
day Trump spoke to people presumably
checked out what Tucker Carlson was
saying Sean Hannity and others and then
he issued on Wednesday morning the
following
not reluctant but not exactly the most
ringing endorsement of Kevin McCarthy
saying on a truth social truth essential
quote
some really good conversations took
place last night and now and it's now
time for all of our great Republican
house members to vote for Kevin close
the deal take the Victory and watch
crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back home to a
very broken California the only speaker
in U.S history to have lost the house
twice Republicans do not turn a great
Triumph into a giant embarrassing defeat
it's time to celebrate you deserve it
Kevin McCarthy will do a good job maybe
even a great job just watch not exactly
a full-throated endorsement and it
appears not to have quite been enough
not to be quite enough to get Kevin
McCarthy over the finish line now I
wrongly assumed yesterday
that it would become less and less
entertaining each time that Kevin
McCarthy lost each time that Kevin
McCarthy failed it has actually become
more entertaining each time because he
seems increasingly exasperated and
desperate now at this point there are
discussions of should Democrats make a
deal with Republicans to vote present
rather than to vote for Hakeem Jeffries
who Democrats have been completely
United behind the idea being or to
abstain from voting altogether and the
idea here is Democrats aren't going to
vote for a republican for house speaker
but would Democrats help lower the
threshold from the 218 needed votes
lower
so that maybe 212 gets Kevin McCarthy
the numbers that he needs I don't
believe democrats should do this the
idea that now it is Democrats who have
to come to the rescue of Republicans
because somewhere between 10 and 20
magats in the house are holding the
speakership hostage it is not for
Democrats to fix that now I recognize
there are National Security risks to not
having a speaker but that's on
Republicans and I hope that Democrats
don't do that the Counterpoint would be
are there six Republicans who can be
bought and who would vote for Hakeem
Jeffries now I don't mean a bribe I
don't mean literally take cash but what
I mean is are there six reasonable
Republicans in the house who are willing
to come to the table with Democrats and
say listen
you guys have a mess on your hands it's
a bigger mess than you know whatever
Trump is Flushing 10 to 15 times or
whatever analogy you want to use you
guys have a mess on your hands we are
united and we are ready to govern and we
could have debt ceiling issues that come
up we could have a natural disaster that
happens which we need to respond to
we've not sworn anyone in we don't have
a speaker this is a problem
be part of the solution we will be
willing to you know bring forward for
debate issues of importance to your
whatever a negotiation like adults are
there six Republicans willing to do that
I think the answer is no but it's worth
exploring that uh if you are the
Democrats before you're going to
acquiesce to these absurd demands from
people like Matt Gates and others it's
completely and totally pathetic so
that's what's going on six losses now
for Kevin McCarthy by the way the record
number of ballots
I believe it's 133 and it was a very
long time ago so we're nowhere close to
the record but certainly for the last
hundred years this is uh this is a
record so that's where we are right now
let's now talk about the explosively
growing Civil War within the the
Republican party and the right wing uh
about what's going on
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
produce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com Pacman use the
free trial to see if your email password
are already out there you may be
surprised the link is down below